[Musique]
même et rivières voilà un chic cheval en
rigole dans le sud de l'île de la
réunion
donc j'ai treize cdi à la maison et tout
ce qu'on plante sur l'exploration on le
transforme d'une façon ou d'une autre et
j'ai la maison du corps humain à la
plaine des radios
alors le salon art et culture me permet
déjà de 1
faire connaître mes produits d'être plus
proche de mes clients parce que j'ai pas
mal de clients surpris et aussi de
promouvoir prend ceux qui viennent qui
vont venir à la réunion dans dans
quelques semaines dans quelques mois de
leur donner le pouls structure de la
maison du climat pour que je sois dans
l'itinéraire de dans leur itinéraire à
l'île de la réunion
alors le village
village réunion bain permet déjà de
montrer ce que nous faisons la réunion
c'est quelque chose de très important
parce que ça fait amis de rassembler pas
mal de producteurs et là nous le devons
conseil général qui a mis vraiment
l'accent sur la production réunionnaise
[Musique]